[Music]
I'm so excited to see the movie
you haven't seen again I would not I
made the unit the link maybe is it
really you in the flesh
this is the important question our Tommy
came really back together when that no I
know like we were old people now what do
you think happened do you have to have
like a theory of what you think happened
oh you know what my hindsight it's just
so bad I you know that yeah they
probably ran off together at some point
and ruin each other's marriages no I'm
just kidding I have no I don't know
I'm sure you've connected with Naomi
Scott I think she's gonna make a
fantastic pink ranger name is god I
really love her yeah I think she's she's
badass and I think she's well that
hasn't a bit more definite even she
really did come from what the interviews
I've seen I hadn't seen me yeah but from
the way she talks about her I hear it it
seems that maybe from what she says her
character is Kim believes a bit more
grounding I'm not sure I have to watch
and say but that would be cool
[Music]
you